so as a companion to our series on
omega-level mutant which focuses on the
evolution of the powers of marvel's
top-tier mutants I wanted to dip my toe
in the water of focusing on mutants with
incredibly crappy powers starting with
Bailey Hoskins so ironically enough
Bailey's first and only appearance in
Marvel Comics came with the five-part
story the worst x-man ever created by
max Bemis and Michael Walsh the concept
of Bailey Hoskins was designed to be a
parody story taking place outside of the
existing Marvel continuity and
presenting us with a scenario about a
mutant that quite literally has the
worst power ever now unlike most of the
x-men and Marvel Comics who were offered
a place at Xavier school after
developing their abilities Bailey's
character didn't take this route instead
his mother had x-ray vision and his
father could produce massive amounts of
heat and because the offspring of two
mutants generally produces a child with
the X gene while they're not 100% sure
Bailey's parents are operating under the
assumption that Bailey himself is a
mutant now where this Factory main
hidden by Bailey's parents for most of
his life because mutant powers normally
manifest between the ages of 12 and 16
years old the time seemed right to
inform Bailey of his mutant heritage do
his parents not knowing what he was
capable of what's also interesting about
this is that instead of being depressed
or fearful due to society's views of
mutants instead Bailey is wildly excited
about the prospect of having powers even
going so far as likening himself to
Harry Potter from here bemis and Walsh
continued the trend of depicting Bailey
as extremely excited when he's brought
before Hank McCoy with the possibility
of being inducted at the Xavier
Institute now the great thing about this
moment is that it actually provides us
with the transition that we don't
normally see what I mean here is that
within the expand you know verse these
transitions did take place in the older
comics but in the modern day
mutants are usually brought before the
x-men whether initiation takes place off
panel after which they officially become
a part of the team but for Bailey the
possibility of becoming an x-man
fighting villains and so on is actually
designed to be a reflection of us as the
reader and that I don't know about you
guys but I think it'd be awesome to be
an x-man and so after going through the
process of being exposed to some testing
equipment designed to analyze and
summarize the nature of his X gene while
Bailey guesses at the possibilities
ranging from growing wings like Warren
Worthington to having a healing factor
like Wolfe
these dreams are these dreams are dashed
to pieces when hey McCoy explains the
Bailey has the ability to explode on
command determining the density and
shape of the explosion meaning that he
could level a city block or wipe out
half a state the downside to this is
that Bailey can only do it once due to
the fact that he'll die in the explosion
and so basically if this power sucks
and so basically Bailey has the power to
explode and then die and that's it
that's all he can do that's the worst
power ever
but anyway where Bailey takes some time
to absorb the nature of his powers and
the fact that they pretty much suck his
life gets even worse when his parents
are killed by the arrival of a sentinel
who lands on them now whoo it was a
synthesis innal and why only one is
there is never explained but this
particular moment is actually designed
to be funny in contrast to the life of
Bailey but what I mean here is that with
Wolverine Iceman Nightcrawler storm and
the rest of the x-men coming into action
the powers they possess are all amazing
especially Colossus and Wolverines
fastball special now for those of you
guys who don't know the fastball special
is a classic maneuver with Colossus and
Wolverine and it literally just involves
Wolverine popping his claws and then
Colossus throwing him at something it's
it's pretty awesome
on the other hand Bayley can't do any of
this stuff all he can do is basically
blow up and die now because Bailey's
power is a one-off and would cost him
his life instead of using his gifts
Bailey doesn't really do anything and is
basically a normal human among the x-men
while he was provided a suit of armor
designed by Forge which would allow him
to contribute to battles and bolster his
self-confidence the problem with this is
that when the x-mansion is attacked by
purifiers which were an extremist group
operating under William Stryker who
believed it was their mission from God
to kill mutants
when Bailey subdues one of the purifiers
he sued for extreme emotional distress
and mental anguish now where the lawsuit
doesn't require Bailey to serve jail
time as fallout of his actions the
Xavier school is forced to provide
monetary compensation after this he was
given positions on x-force x-factor the
New Mutants in beta flight all of which
were ancillary teams of the x-men with
the exception of beta Flight who were
the secondary team to Canada's Alpha
Flight superhero team the issue here
is that Bailey kept making everyone mad
by being socially awkward when he was on
the x-force team he didn't contribute
anything mostly because he didn't have
what it took to kill people without
mercy when he was on x-factor he was
being weird by mentioning havoc as being
the crappy Summers brother and when he
was on beta flight we actually dedup
leaving because beta flight and alpha
fly pretty much suck
I'm sorry Canada fans but alpha flight
sucks but regarding his powers but where
the rest of the story would see Bailey
continuing to try to find his place in
the school his unique power also drew
the attention of Magneto and his
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants including
mystique toad blob and pyro who looked
to kill Professor Charles Xavier and
disband the x-men Matt were the initial
indication was that magneto sought to
use Bailey to blow up the school and
kill Xavier in the process after a fight
broke out between Bailey and another
student at the school named riches who
could turn anything into gold it was
revealed that riches himself was
actually an Inside Man working for
Magneto because the two had been sent to
the office of Xavier for fighting while
Professor X informing that their roles
as x-men would be useless regarding a
peaceful coexistence between humans and
mutants if they couldn't achieve peace
among each other
riches used the opportunity to achieve
his mission by turning Xavier's tongue
to gold causing him to choke to death in
the process and so with the x-men would
disband riches rallied the mutant youth
under himself after which humanity was
pushed to the brink of extinction and
riches seize control of the world
and so after receiving an invitation to
a gala held by Richards in celebration
of his conquering of the world while
Bailey's invitation was given for the
purpose of riches making fun of Bailey
and the idea that he couldn't really do
anything
Bailey sees his riches by the neck and
detonates destroying himself riches in
the entire building in the process with
that being said we're gonna bring this
video to an end
and let me know down in the comments
section if you find these videos to be
interesting let me know if you want to
see them continue and yeah I will catch
you guys later please
you